now to russia's war in ukraine the
largest city in western ukraine has been
hit by a series of air strikes flames
lit up the night sky over la viv after
the russian missile strikes the city's
mayor says three electrical substations
were among the damaged buildings and
that caused a power outage
and the russian assault on the steel
plant in mariopol which only led up
briefly to allow a few dozen civilians
to escape is still going on there is
some good news about those who got out
on sunday they finally arrived in the
ukrainian city of zapposia today
redmond shannon reports and a warning
some of the images in his story are
upsetting
the relief is palpable some show it with
smiles others with tears after a
gruelling journey through back roads and
russian army checkpoints the azov style
evacuees arrive to safety the end of a
two-month nightmare beneath the
bombarded steelworks in mariupol
you can't imagine how scary it is when
you sit in the shelter in a wet and damp
basement which is bouncing shaking
every night we went to sleep and thought
about whether we would survive and wake
up the united nations says 101 civilians
including 17 children made it out most
of them arriving in zapposia we would
have hoped that much more people would
be able to join the convoy
and to get out of hell some estimates
say around 200 civilians are still
inside the red cross says the renewed
bombardment of the plant since sunday
prevents any more evacuations extremely
concerned with the image we have seen
today we have seen that hostilities have
resumed
technical
ukrainian forces claim those hostilities
now include tanks and ground troops and
that two civilian women were killed
overnight i have
one
message
for you today
ukraine will win
british prime minister boris johnson
gave a virtual address to ukraine's
parliament the first foreign leader to
do so since russia's invasion in
february you have proved them completely
wrong every one of those military
experts who said that ukraine would fall
johnson pledged another half billion
dollars in new military aid to ukraine
france's emanuel macron meanwhile spent
two hours on the phone with vladimir
putin demanding but not getting a
ceasefire agreement from the russian
leader redmond shannon double news
london